I'm not how do you balance that are
there comedians though who don't see it
that way who are a little bit out of
touch and a little bit of this like
disillusioned about where they're
actually at I mean that they think
they're they're higher than they are you
guys like gals I guess you know I know a
couple like that yeah I mean I just want
to say I don't want to say no no don't
who I like her but eliza right does she
said a couple of things don't know why
she's felt so funny to me okay let's
move on
see if doesn't even feel right I love
Eliza she's a friend of mine okay she is
huge though she's pretty big yeah yeah
well she just had that thing but to say
she said I'm Co a female
what'd she say I'm the only female comic
doing interesting so she's all about
other people he basically said which was
was I'm the only you know I want female
to stop going onstage and talking about
their vaginas or whatever let's rise
above that I'm the only female and then
someone posted a picture she has a
vagina and somebody then pointed out the
fact that her entire Instagram is all
like selfies oh yeah well you see that's
the thing you see you see and this is
nothing against Eliza but she put
herself out there like that and got slam
yeah because yes her instagrams are just
like hot pictures of her yeah all right
there because it's like I'm the comic
I'm the female comic talking about the
important issues yeah you know yeah
right she what a funny girl though saij
she is so funny yeah no I mean you love
you know I mean I love Maria Bamford I
love her though that's true right yeah
he's like people love tag my favorites
people love me I think is amazing to
watch no TIG is like whoa I wish I could
do she never I'm always screaming
onstage my voice gets gets cut to shreds
she's like this
hmmm yes there were bees that got in my
car today and it's just beautiful and it
just flows and it's so [ __ ] funny
yeah
and she never raises her voice more no
like yeah but she's funny I love them
Judy gold he's my favorite favorite
favorite
really now you pulling things now now
like beauty gold like what's asian lady
named Tamayo to my Otsu she was a she
was the [ __ ] she was look her up she
was a Japanese one of the first [ __ ] in
his comedians as she headline I when I
open I'm open for her back in the 90s
she went crazy and she now lives in a
jungle in Hawaii and she I'm not kidding
no I'm just thinking of comics you know
she she she [ __ ] she went crazy
she lives in the jungle and she eats cat
meat like that's she showed me the
pictures she hunts kept there had to be
those she used to be Sam's kinases
girlfriend she used to be on TV shows
wishy comic yeah fine and up was she
funny she would have the only thing I
don't like about her she like I mean you
look at someone like Ali Wong right
who's very contemporary yes she she
doesn't have an axe and she doesn't talk
about really Asian anything and she does
yeah but still Tamayo wore a kimono
you know man she know that was her name
yeah yeah yeah I by my feet walk on your
background what you see when you
pigeonhole yourself into the ethic an
SNL character like I'm only this person
[Music]